let's talk about Nigeria and its oil
Nigeria is Africa's top oil producer and
oil is the government's biggest source
of revenue but the economy has been
struggling and poverty levels are on the
rise the poverty of those living around
the source of Nigeria's wealth is bare
to see
so what cat Nigerians depend on their
country's oil wealth what happens to all
that money they call Nigeria the African
giant for a reason
it's home to Africa's biggest population
and largest economy powered by a growing
services industry and agricultural
exports like cocoa and palm oil it has
Nollywood Africa's biggest film industry
fashion houses of booming music business
and a very wealthy elite including the
richest man in Africa Alico dongho tape
Nigeria also has a lot of natural
resources minerals gold and oil lots of
oil it's got the second largest proven
reserves on the African continent and is
the 12th largest producer worldwide and
yet many Nigerians have it hard world
poverty clock says 90 million people
live not just in poverty but extreme
poverty that's 48 percent of the
population compare that to 24% in
Ethiopia and 16 percent in Kenya and
they don't even have oil
despite Nigeria's vast oil wealth half
its population lives on less than $2 a
day
now you'd think a resource-rich country
like Nigeria could rely on some of that
oil wealth the thing is the Nigerian
government does but that's part of the
problem Nigeria's government depends on
oil for as much as 75 percent of its
revenue so when global oil prices bottom
down in 2014 Nigeria went into recession
and it's still struggling to get out but
even when oil prices are good
Nigerian experts say not a huge slice of
that revenue gets to the people who
should be their money's got the Indian
government gets how much is reinvested
into their lives other people you're
still using some of that oil revenue to
pay off debts and the rest to pay
salaries to the lawmakers so things like
schools hospital infrastructure
much-needed infrastructure does not get
built okay so where does that revenue go
let's follow the money on the oil
Nigerian crude is found right here under
the waterways of the Niger Delta a few
Nigerian companies operate there but the
ones doing most of the exploring and
extracting are international companies
shell is one of the big ones it provides
40 percent of Nigeria's oil production
but because Nigeria doesn't have the
infrastructure to refine its own crude
oil these foreign companies that sell it
abroad and in the end Nigeria has to
import billions of dollars worth of
refined oil back in a multinational
actually exercise the oil so if they
think that finally the oil in in
Switzerland or refined anything and then
the entities will help them lower cost
definitely that's where they will do it
because the capacity to refine it isn't
there in Nigeria now what Nigeria does
have is a central body called the
Nigerian national petroleum corporation
the NNPC is both an oil industry
regulator and a massive commercial
corporation the corporation arm signs
contracts with all those international
companies and the companies pay for all
the initial costs plus things like oil
licenses royalties and
on their profits to the NNPC so the NNPC
takes all that money and pays it into
Nigeria's National Treasury but the
regulator that's supposed to police that
flow of money is part of the unempioyed
set there is a huge lack of transparency
that a lot of transactions are happening
under a cloak of obscurity you cannot be
both a regulator and a player you can't
be a referee and a player as well it
just doesn't make any sense that lack of
transparency has led to corruption in
the oil sector billions of dollars in
oil money have gone missing over the
years one of the most infamous cases was
back in 2016 it was reported that 16
billion u.s. dollars in oil revenue had
just gone missing and this money was
supposed to be given from an MPC and
sent to the National Treasury but the
money was not sent over so every few
years and Niger in headlines you see
things like 16 billion missing 30
billion missing there's another type of
missing oil money and that's taxes as we
mentioned earlier international oil
companies are supposed to pay taxes on
their oil profits to the NNPC the
companies are accused of reporting lower
profits in order to pay fewer taxes so a
company can sell my Darien oil at a
lower price to its own subsidiary in a
tax haven and then sell that oil to
other buyers at full price they can
inflate the costs of their Nigerian
operations or underreport the volume of
oil they produced to begin with
so public oil money gets lost in a swamp
of tax havens and murky accounting and
then there's theft yes straight-up
stealing
[Music]
tucked in the forest we find these men
cooking oil there are hundreds of
illegal refineries in the Niger Delta
where criminal gangs like the Delta
Avengers tap into pipelines in early
2019
22 million barrels of oil were stolen
and sold on the black market the barges
then take it the larger tankers in the
Atlantic Ocean and from there to buyers
in West Africa Europe Latin America and
as far as Asia there's even a language
in Nigeria that conveys and captures a
sentiment that the oil is here to steal
for example you would hear a phrase an
idea called the national cake and that
just means the oil money oil companies
like she'll blame these attacks from
massive oil spills and fires but human
rights group Amnesty International says
oil companies are also responsible for
the spills and accuse them of misleading
and neglecting local communities so
sabotage theft tax evasion corruption
lots to tackle but Nigeria's government
has been releasing annual audit reports
on its energy industry demanding unpaid
taxes and compensation from
international oil companies and after 17
years of delays is ready to implement
the petroleum industries bill the bill
has its critics but many in Nigeria hope
it will clean up the oil sector by doing
things like splitting the N&P seas
commercial business from its regulator
Nigeria also says it wants to diversify
its economy away from oil and there are
signs it wants to develop its own
industry to cut back on all the foreign
involvement remember Alico dangoty
Africa's richest man he's building a new
refinery near Lagos we have to make sure
that oil is actually refined duty
Nigeria and that will help you know
reduce importing they will find that
you're up to that technology now none of
that will single-handedly fix Nigeria's
oil industry its economy
or poverty levels but the hope is it'll
go some way to getting Nigerians a
bigger slice of that national cake
thanks for watching commenting sharing
and giving us your feedback it's been
really helpful for us to see what's been
working and which stories you'd like us
to tackle next
if you haven't yet subscribe and like
all those aljazeera pages so you're
always in the loop see you next week
you
[Music]